[Musique]
soit tous
je sais pas si vous vous asseyez vous
entendez donc je m'appelle il ya c'est
ma douche en effet chez docteur en arts
et j'essaye de créer des installations
qui modifie la perception du temps du
spectateur très simplement là vous avez
une oeuvre qui s'appelle un sur 60 et
qui a une certaine logique de
fonctionnement que je vais vous
expliquer après je vous invite à vous
concentrer dessus
christian boltanski disait qu'il y avait
trois sujets en art il ya l'amour le
sexe la mort la mort c'est un peu la
perception du temps la mort c'est la
vanité ultime la mort c'est notre
rapport à l'existence et le temps c'est
notre rapport à l'existant ce qu'ont
acquis soit le plus subjectif par nous
tous c'est à dire que que c'est une
expérience qui est intrinsèquement pas
partageable
chacun a la sienne par exemple moi j'ai
une montre de poignet qui est un peu
qu'ils assad particulier que c'est juste
un cylindre en est on pardon pour ce
qu'ils voient pas au fond mais qui vit
pour toutes les cinq minutes
alors évidemment quand je parle avec
quelqu'un de particulièrement ennuyant
je le ressens parce que ça vibre et je
le sens que saïb mais quand temps passe
vite les choses sont plus simples et du
coup j'oublie complètement qu'il est en
train de vivre et ça peut sembler être
un supplice mais c'en est pas pas du
tout en finale évidemment l'une des
autres raisons pour lesquelles on peut
parler tant c'est que le temps aidant
une accélération perpétue perpétuelle
est constante
on vit dans un monde où tout va de plus
en plus vite les distances disparaissent
et on parle en temps je suis là dans 20
je suis là je peux la dans le 15 km mais
je suis à dans 20 minutes je suis à nant
dans dans une heure je suis là dedans
donc on a l'impression de se téléporter
d'endroit en endroit il ya un petit
rapport elle avec la téléportation là
dedans et dans ma recherche par rapport
aux installations qu'ils puissent
modifier la perception du temps j'ai été
amené à utiliser un outil assez simple
qui s'appelle l'hypnose alors ça peut
faire peur mais y'a pas de quoi parce
que c'est quelque chose qu'on éprouve
tous les jours les sciences cognitives
le définissent comme un état modifié de
conscience qui a fait de particulier que
finalement on les ponts les prouve tous
les jours sauf que pour les sciences
cognitives c'est quand on défini au
préalable un objectif qu'on rentre dans
un état hypnotique
donc il ya tout plein de systèmes et eux
l'utilisent pour les recherches tous les
quotidiennes pour créer un état
standards de la pensée qui peuvent
étudier et partager avec leurs pairs
donc un état de conscience répétable qui
est un état d'hypnose et qui peuvent
faire mécaniquement ils ont des
protocoles pour le faire et il ya des
mécanismes il ya des systèmes et serré
c'est là que je me suis intéressé et
vous allez le voir dans la prochaine
vidéo et dès qu'elle arrive que
ces systèmes m'en inspirer d'une façon
de façon multiple
par exemple vous avez un sablier alors
le sablier un compteur juste en dessous
il a un dispositif en son centre qui
compte le passage des microbilles de
verre qui le composent c'est un peu mon
fantasme et essayer de comprendre
combien de de compter combien il ya de
microbilles de verre dans un sablier
parce qu'on sait que ça a une durée
d'écoulement constants mais à chaque
fois qu'on le retourne il va y avoir un
tout petit delta qui va faire un
décalage
premièrement parce que les billes vont
s'éroder vont à rodez le passage du coup
il y aura toujours plus de billes qui
passeront et deuxièmement mon mon
système est un peu foireux ont fait
parce qu'il ya juste un laser avec une
photodiode et des microbilles de verre
qui passe donc à chaque fois que vous
retournez le sablier si vous y arrivez
pas ce qui est particulièrement lourd et
que le système recommence mais il va
vous filer un nouveau nombre et il va de
vous donner encore un nouveau nombre est
encore un nouveau nombre et donc on
arrive dans une espèce de 2,2
d'approximations du nombre de hobbies
mais que qu'on n'arrive jamais à
quantifier et le sablier a quelque chose
de fascinant qui est bien sûr lié avec
la vanité du temps parce que on regarde
ça c'est cool et et il ya autre chose
qui est un autre outil assez fascinant
qu'on peut d'ailleurs trouver dans les
cabinets de l'hypnotiseur c'est les
boules de cristal pour savoir que ça
existait déjà au xviiie siècle que avant
que les musées existe on avait ce qu'on
appelait les cabinets de curiosités et
les grands propriétaires pouvaient avoir
tout un tas d'objets miraculeux et les
boules de cristal en faisait partie
au xviiie siècle n'était pas répandue du
tout comme objet savez une facture
tellement impressionnante qu'il
suffisait simplement d'observer à
travers pour être dans un état modifié
de conscience et du coup les hypnotiseur
du xviiie siècle utilisé comme un outil
pour pour pour créer un état modifié de
conscience il ya un deuxième moyen des
ducs d'induction hypnotique dont vous
avez certainement entendu parler c'est
celui de du pendule le pendule quand on
connaît avec le cinéma d'abstrait le
cinéma obstructionniste allemand
expressionniste allemand s'est baladé un
pendule devant vos yeux et vous dire
vous avez eu envie de dormir vous
vous vos paupières se ferment vos yeux
sont lourds et vous vous reposez vous
avez envie de dormir lorsque vous avez
c'est la multiplicité de plans dans
cette pièce qui vous font aller tout le
temps d'un côté à l'autre et essayer de
comprendre le mécanisme est la personne
qui a devant cette pièce se demande mais
comment ça se fait que ça bouge
de temps en temps alors que finalement
cette mécanique elle est branchée à
léonov lelas mécanisme bouge en
permanence mais y
il ya un mouvement qui est complètement
aléatoire c'est simplement dû à un
ensemble de frottement est ce qui
m'intéressait là dedans c'était de
parler d' un systématisme d'une approche
mécanique et de la mettre en corrélation
avec un simplement une étrangeté dans
les faits qu'elle produisait et cette
étrangeté ça crée le décalage qui
finalement vous faire entrer dans un
dans un état modifié de conscience
c'est ça en fait l'idée c'est que c'est
d'essayer de créer une esthétique mon
travail où vous avez quelque chose qui
semble rationnel dans son fonctionnement
mais qui dans le produit dans l'effet
qu'il produit ne l'est pas du tout essai
c'est ce que fait cette pièce là que
j'ai continué avec cette troisième pièce
qui est il faut prêter attention où vous
pouvez peut-être voir que la boule de
cristal qui est tout en haut est en
train de tourner elle est parcourue de
laser qui est l'instrument article de
l'étude scientifique et donc vous voyez
elle repose simplement sur trois moteurs
et quand elle tourne on voit toutes les
imperfections de surface et simplement
ce dans cet objet qui est magnifique je
cherchais en révéler les mécaniques
c'est à dire révélé pendant les
mécaniques de la boule de cristal c'est
à dire montrer comment elle est faite
parce que le laser et diffracté et
projette au mur toutes les imperfections
qui assure la sphère qui semble a priori
parfaite et en même temps créer un
espace du dispositif de fascination qui
peut faire penser aux as qui peut faire
penser à l'exploration spatiale et qui
peuvent servir comme amorce hypnotique
mais pour finir je vais vous je reviens
à cette pièce là qui a une logique
particulière dans son fonctionnement
qu'on comprend surtout au début
à chaque seconde qui s'écoule la
trotteuse se fractionne d'un segment
supplémentaires c'est à dire que là
comme elle prend le car je peux deviner
qu'il ya quinze secondes comme elle
prend le 18 et le une fraction
supplémentaire
je peux deviner qu'il ya à peu près 20
secondes et elle va continuer et si vous
prêtez particulièrement attention vous
allez voir que le mouvement est en train
de s'accélérer encore et encore et
encore
elle est le système va continuer à se
fragmenter et dans cette boîte de pétri
qui est toute blanche et qui est
complètement expérimental
parce que j'essaye d'inviter la personne
à faire comme expérience
c'est celui de du ralentissement de la
perception du temps parce que c'est un
effet secondaire de l'hypnose à chaque
séance d'hypnose que vous générez chez
quelqu'un vous allez lui demander parce
qu'il faut tout de suite coupé avec peu
ce qui s'est fait combien de temps vous
avez ressenti qui s'est écoulé depuis le
début de la séance et il va vous dire
demi heure
et en fait ce sera toujours un temps
ralenti qu'il aura perçu et qui est d'un
rapport du double donc cette pièce qui
va comme ça se fragmenter se fragmenter
se fragmenter elle marche sur la même le
même système que je viens de vous viens
de vous expliquer si l'idée que c'est
l'idée d'un biais cognitifs qui est
simple c'est que vous avez un système
qui est logique et qui au final commence
a progressivement dépassé votre
entendement il va saturer votre
perception et vous n'allez plus pouvoir
le comprendre complètement explicitement
mais mais votre cerveau inconscient va
complètement va savoir quelle est la
mécanique qu'il régit et plus vous
avancerez dans cette mécanique
plus vous allez rentrer dans un état
modifié de conscience un état que vous
faites en général tout le monde fait de
manière quotidienne en prenant une
douche en conduisant une voiture et en
est je sais pas en écoutant par exemple
quelqu'un de parler en conférence parce
qu'il est profondément concentrée dans
c'est un propos qui est constant et qui
va parler de cette manière là et là par
exemple ce que je suis en train de faire
c'est qu'est ce qui pourrait
s'apparenter à une forme d'hypnose
conversationnel et c'est simplement le
fait de parler avec plusieurs termes
techniques et de ne jamais quitter ce
même flux monotone de parole et
continuer jusqu'à ce qu'un fils que la
concentration soit complètement dilapidé
dans le propos est que finalement vous
soyez vous même tous chacun dans vos
pensées et dans vos pensées
c'est exactement ce que ce qu'on appelle
un dans un état modifié de conscience
est ce que je souhaite faire avec ça
c'est simplement démystifier ce qui est
là l'hypnose l'hypnose c'est juste un
outil qu'on a tous sur soi qui est un
outil d'une ce qu'on pourrait appeler de
reprogrammation de soi et que vous
pouvez faire l'expérience par exemple
certains d'entre vous le feront
probablement maintenant vous pouvez la
faire dans la rue l'ennui vous pouvez le
faire de manière consciente ou semi
consciente mais cet outil de
reprogrammation de soi c'est énorme que
vous avez tous et que vous pouvez
utiliser qui a plusieurs vertus et
notamment en thérapeutique
c'est ce que j'essaye de partager dans
mon travail est dans mon coeur est avec
vous ce soir
merci pour votre attention
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]